if you make like you never call and then
there was this time when I had a date
with a girl and I had spent lots of
money on making a perfect day together
like I had set up everything perfectly
and I went on the subway over an hour
and I stood on the train on the train
station and I looked for her for two
hours before I was like okay
she gave her I knew it man
listen half year ago recently I mean
it's happened plenty times when I was
much younger but it happened recently I
was like you stop II really breath i was
so cheesed when it happened cuz I
remember because I remember messaging
the person ahead of time but you'll be
still good and again and then the day I
was like yeah I'll see you at 3:00 and
they didn't respond and I never
responded after that no they did No then
I went home and she wrote that when she
saw me I was so ugly she never talked to
me again like you never talk to me again
I'm cool like I'd be like Oh word that's
gonna be cool but you give me a
rinky-dink ass burn man's mother oh no
that is more insulting than just you
know I'll disagree with you on this
point even though she gave me a
rinky-dink answer her rinky-dink answer
was indicative of me that she wasn't
interested so even though she didn't say
those words I knew that's what it meant
do you dig what I'm saying but you have
the nerve to come back met Fred [ __ ]
sesh I'm didn't now I've been back if
you black powder back salem you could
have said
okay you made me waste them two hours I
waited I'm never gonna have back and you
gotta come back no that is unacceptable
there you go you could take it I think
it's funny that I've been stood up many
times and I'm not that mad about it
you've never been stood up and you been
with your girl forever and you never
gonna have to deal with that and you
this
infuriates me man I kid not [ __ ] I've
never seen you this obsession but I
cannot even understand your voices crap
yes because I cannot even understand
that someone with and then you have the
nerve to call me back the next day like
everything is not good
oh sorry no no no no no do you think I
am some [ __ ] people do that yeah oh
but you remember I told you sorry you
give me the gym story that's some [ __ ]
that's better and a half to three
quarters but we're not gonna argue over
a quarter of it right whatever
oh I got that but that's some other [ __ ]
and how old were you when the gym [ __ ]
happen 17:17 how old she the girl that
stood me up yeah she was 18 18 right I
understand you're young you're dumb full
of [ __ ]
you stupid right when this person did
that you know I did so they must admit a
later and I was like yeah what happened
it's like oh I got caught up with my
sister she's going through some show she
write and I was like you couldn't just
tell me realize it's not a big deal you
didn't wanna come on the date I said no
no it's not that
I was like okay I blocked on Facebook
block I just blocked off everything and
I knew she liked messaging the page a
couple times so I blocked on all their
social medias yeah yeah I don't want to
see her face
no I'm not mad at you I'm not gonna send
your anger messages cubed don't try to
contact me afterwards
no you wasted my time okie don't mix my
own I got cut up with my yo you could
have said something
you could have texted me
and their maids there's no excuse it's
not like you got a page or something
it's not like you got a pager oh here's
something petty I would me okay I don't
say anything to the people but if you
cross me that way I don't want to see
your name or your face anywhere so I
will just block you off everything yeah
not to get mad or to hit at you I just
know I will be annoyed if I see your
name so I'm just like stay away I
understand
but anyways on some real stuff it is a
very frustrating feeling to show up with
intent uh uh you know for an event and
then for the other party to not sure
whether to not warn you and to not let
you know and to leave you in the dark
it's a frustrating thing there's people
like their app if you're late if you
never show up and you picked me you text
me the next day breath
it was it was upset next day but it was
absurd and look I'm gonna repeat what I
said earlier just in case you got cut
off but like listen if you have a date
with somebody meet your application and
if you don't want to if you want to back
out that's your right tell the other
person do not waste their time that is
the most infuriating it is it is one of
the saddest things to be waiting for
somebody that you aren't sure is gonna
come Mitra applications right we always
talk about how it's annoying when
someone's deceitful to us and they waste
our time and relationships right right
they think they present themselves as
someone who this is no different when
you say alright I'll make there I take
it that you are someone with integrity
and when you don't show up to the date
that means you've misrepresented who you
are and you've wasted my time you are no
different than what women always like to
complain about which is fuckboys right
always I don't like ask that's some
[ __ ] it is so please don't do that
show up or if not tell a lie I don't
care get the light if you have to lie a
lie tell the lie I don't give if it
means you're not gonna waste that
person's time tell a lie I would prefer
you tell the treason saying I'm not
interested but just tell life so they
don't show up and waste hours of 13
drug wants to make efforts to speak in
Portuguese from you yeah yes because
when you are doing a quiz I like it I
like it the way you were asking
questions you know because before this I
thought you the Arab people were stupid
you know but now when we are doing this
video you you stand you're happy I still
my happy we have no problem Kiwis doing
I'm gonna say dodo birds what the dodo
bird that's part of a cartoon I believe
I thought it was a Pokemon for a long
time he said and I didn't know what bird
to say Muslims Buddhists Hindus
Christians honestly I thought this was a
trick question
so I'm like me no no I know cuz I'm part
of that group we're not that know you
used to be part of that correct
but you know what they say you know you
can't quit on Islam Islam quits on you
and when there's a quit on you when you
go to hell
I think what do they call people who
leave the religion it was award for no
[Laughter]